kayla is with us in Colorado hi Kayla
how are you I'm great Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up all
right well I'm 28 and I'm on may be set
to after jad for a couple of months I
have a little bit over 150,000 dollars
in debt 139,000
give or take his student loan and forty
three thousand dollars of that is Parent
PLUS loans and not only do I hate that
interest rate of seven point six five
percent which is outrageous I feel a
moral obligation to take him off my arm
and put them on my own credit history so
I'm looking at a parent loan refinancing
and I was just wondering what your
thoughts were on that I have some more
details but I'll I'll stop there you
found a loan that is offering for you to
refinance your mother student loan debt
that she took it yeah yep by four
percent I was her neighbor your name in
in my name I could reduce it almost four
percent and get it out of her ink and
get it out of her name exactly and the
there's no question that you are
supposed to pay this I mean the deal you
made with your mom was you're you were
going to pay it I've always been paying
it yep I've never she's never paid a
dollar on it I've always paid it because
it's my obligation it's just I've just
done the minimum payments and kind of
just let it go okay if you're taking it
on as one of your student loans in
mathematically you might as well take it
on legally and especially if you say 4%
there's no downside to this discussion
then the one question I had on Dave is
obviously this would increase my monthly
payment by about $400 which I can do
I've been sticking to the everyday
dollar like religiously but your
argument on this yes yeah yeah yeah I am
but it would just increase my total
payment my minimum payment by about $400
for that loan why the
structuring the loan in a way that makes
the payment go up because you're already
paying your mother's payment right yes
and you're getting a cheaper interest
rate than she has so why is your payment
going up because it's not the way that
we chose to do it was on an incremental
basis on the refinancing it's through
Naviance oh so we started on one of
those 2-year incremental things I got
you okay yeah so it's artificially low
now and you're just gonna you're gonna
own that okay yeah I think you still go
ahead and do this still makes sense
because you're you've decided that this
is your obligation at some point in this
process and so Parent PLUS loans are not
always morally the student's obligation
so but that's the that's the deal you
all have made and I'm okay with that if
that's what the deal you made was